[Musique]
oui beaucoup surtout en premier plat
voici une recette simple et délicieuse
les spaghettis à la bolognaise qui
feront un merveilleux plat de départ
comme on les déguste en italie dans un
faitout vous avez mis de l'eau beaucoup
d'eau
ce sont ces petits trucs qui assureront
la réussite d'un plat réputé simple
ajouter le sel avant cuisson couvrez
pour hâter l'ébullition
et pendant ce temps vous préparez un
coulis de tomates fraîches de préférence
en ajoutant un peu de boeuf haché à
l'assaisonnement l'eau bout mettez-y ce
bouquet de spaghettis mais attention
sans les casser
plongée n'est petit à petit pour les
ramollir comme ceci
[Musique]
vous aurez les séduire
et maintenant vous vérifié cette cuisson
sont-elles transparentes sont elles
légèrement croquantes
alors c'est à point
[Musique]
égouttez soigneusement dans la passoire
et remettez dans le faitout pour
assaisonner
[Musique]
à
pour cela il faut du beurre beaucoup de
beurre
et vous allez mêlée et démêler ce plat
qui sent si bon qu'une invitée ne peut
résister elle a envie de venir et goûter
[Musique]
malgré sa hâte n'oubliez pas la sauce
cette sauce tomate et d'aromates dont
vous saupoudrez le tout avec un peu de
gruyère ou mieux de parmesan râpé
voilà servait vite c'est john personnes
affamées et rassurer la car les
spaghettis à la bolognaise ont une vertu
capitale ils ne font pas grossir
[Musique]